por qu Meu Deus a gente só lembra de
pegar a toalha depois que já se molhou
vai tomar banho lembra de ir pro
banheiro lembra de cantar lembra de
lavar o cu mas não lembro de pegar a
desgraça da toalha que que as células
Leonildo jaab boeco Leonardo ele tá indo
tomar banho e o que é que tem Deixa o
bingem se limpar rapaz eu não tô vendo
toalha no ombro dele não tô nada a ver
com isso não isso aí é com um negócio do
cérebro lá aí o cara toma banho Cadê a
toalha tem ninguém em casa aí você dá o
grito da misericórdia que é quando você
tá pedindo por ajuda mesmo que é isso
aqui ó ei
Man se a mãe não vi é porque não tá em
casa aí você fala Cadê a toalha tá no
teu quarto não tá lá no quintal num
varal em Rondônia ela tem que atravessar
a casa inteira nu mãe ei mãe e um freio
da desgraça atravessa a casa pelado para
pegar a toalha depois de tomar banho e
fica gelado e conferindo mãe e tu
morrendo de medo pensando assim meu Deus
do céu se minha mãe chegar e eu tiver
atravessando a casa pelada eu vou ter
que ir embora PR Lagoas como é que eu
vou conviver com a minha mãe depois que
ela me viu nu e não vai ter nem que se
orgulhar pombinha ré no gelado